[Applause]
showing good evening
mercy for hardworking northern farm
girls yes welcome thank you how are you
fine thank you
Judith I thinking who's got one out me
Justin would you do modeling I felt that
you sell septic tanks yeah bottom under
the market so you think we [__] all day
yes that's one thing we ought to do this
evening until we [__] yes yes yes the
high-scoring brigades okay across the
whole series they're coming to run my
restaurant at Claridge's yes so do dish
what's on the menu pea salad with
poached duck egg and pancetta right off
we go
four covers Table eight on order four
duck salad for halibut for Scotch
pancake excellent cool that [__]
squeak right let me show you how to do
the first table first thing that goes on
blood on basically little matchsticks
cut out the pancetta yes to get rid of
the excess fat so we get this really
nice crispy lard on at the end okay now
water is spinning around there nicely
yes vinegars in there and then it's
telling around that way so we go in up
and straight in yes okay what we got in
there I don't want the peas too hot they
get too hot they discolor okay I'm gonna
put the larvae straight in there okay
yes
toss it all together nice small portions
no taste and margin police under pick
margarine right the last minute in there
now the idea of the yolk is for what
yeah the nice richness of the yolk you
have to give a really nice sort of
source effect for the peas right
advantage over your fingers are small
don't be scared to serve four okay eggs
out please nice and carefully plates
down nice simple straightforward cooking
tank with a pepper good looks watch key
margin on top of the egg fresh margin go
please and then a really nice
toughen us on all of you one simple
question would you pay 8 pounds for that
yeah you [__] better cuz I made it
all like that yes right let's go ladies
please please whistling me Susan yes
your boyfriend put up with that voice
you still single
mr. French Munoz yeah go please yes a
single white loud female yes
there's no [__] your next more peas and
pisses in the bath on a [__] holiday
ladies the confidence levels is
fantastic yes yes
someone's toast is burning toast is
burning we sell alarm on that [__]
grill yes come on Lady
wakey-wakey you may eat [__] you burn
toast up north but we're in [__]
London [__] Hilda Ogden let's go
having for Jana Street Porter's the kids
yes they're burnt all right yeah when
they burst the egg yo you want the egg
yolk the richness of the egg yolk
running all over the teams right well
done very very nice indeed go please yes
14 its go let's go quick
it's nice to be back in the kitchen with
women for change 10:55 doing milk round
use the finish work and about 5:30 6:00
pick the children up
what's in the tea shop all day long past
four in the morning the alarm goes up so
I get up through the metro I love to
call it dessert chocolate lemon meringue
roulade you've anything from real peace
fresh steak chicken need you to get
quite stressful each other when we work
together
something's burning in here from
Lancashire a really sort of upfront and
in-your-face basically a salmon Judith
dudes are told a fair amount of things
we will be the best regret that Gardens
ever have because we're hard-working a
conscientious girl's gotta show you
something I'm going to show it back
because we came into this world exactly
with them Israelis going to grow to this
world exactly the same as me look how
good and here we come you're supposed to
be toasting you're not burning it yes
clean up messy unbelievable
let's go let's go let's go eggs please
dad nice very nice very very nice well
done well done well done
Claire down yes the next course yes well
done yeah it was a bit snotty and all
it's overpowering just too salty bacon
suckling yeah something I've never tried
before so
quite a ladies let's go let's go please
come over results yes for the startup
okay Jamie yeah move until you please
out of fifteen
only 33 egg whites tour like watching
mm-hmm and yeah and the presentation
yeah I saw the place yes I thought you
did a [__] good job no no main course
I had a book make sure you get 50 out of
50 okay let's go next on the menu denise
Van Outen makes me forget my table
manners doesn't Andrew Lloyd Webber's
Facebook everything the RAF take fast
food - Mac -
I mean that yeah and I've already wet my
pants
and I challenge Top Gear's James May to
a culinary duel
this is Bulls penis Bulls penis
[Music]
James how I very good
good to see you remind you nice shirt
thank you huh it's one of my regulars
how would you start very tasty
yes to be honest it's sort of almost a
posh fryer you've got bacon a poached
egg and then you've got like the bubble
and squeak but without the potato bit
and my top get you're always portrayed
as the whim the one who's always coming
behind Jeremy behind Hammond flats as a
got Hammonds become a hero on the back
of the crash I'm just a bloke that
married but don't have any kids
I have a cat I can turn that around and
show them yet you're the most manly out
all three of them I've got an idea
simple test so JP please it's the test
of a man it's a test of a real man it's
snake whisky
it's from Laos so that is a real snake
in the yeah there's this several there
but it's dangerous isn't it well done
any thoughts back it's quite light
really it's quite quite he spent too
much time without Clark you know that
second please every this is this is
Bulls penis this is for me this is to
prove your manliness it's huge in China
it's huge on your face it's very good
for getting things going sort of
downstairs and any particular well I'll
have I'll have the scan where it all
starts from the side if you gave me from
sort of from there to there that's the
hilt
I'll go into the helmet so this is a
bull's [__] yes
and this has probably been in a lady cow
something well I'd like I'd like to
think so I don't want that poor bull to
die happy actually that's gonna say it's
a bit stiff but I didn't mean that I
forgot to say this boy a rubber like you
sorry
right the biggest challenge thanks Jamie
now this one is extraordinary and this
is a this is an amazing delicacy from
Iceland it's like it's a blue whale's
penis and it's basically rotten shark
now it's being put in the ground yeah
covered in gravel for up to three months
and on the back of that is hung for four
months and it is a local delicacy in a
way that you have to eat it without
being sick and that is the sort of true
definition of a proper man yes god it
does [__] ahh
traditionally i can't--it's wash down
with the glass of brennidon okay it's
like a rich firewater ready buddy no
pull that back out one two three
oh [__] you disappoint me Ramsey dad God
Almighty shoe it yeah
Oh James don't me to do it again
congratulations well good I wouldn't
actually recommend that I will put you
yes at the top of the pole I guess
having second yeah Clarkson third thank
you very much millions well done
see also use it for cooking fish now
some nice and generally just a set of
cutters poaching an egg so but take this
be part boiled so it all got do now some
color on there
yes in watch this evening please ladies
yes yes chef turn out of it slightly
fourth is a fans always my color but
with a cucumber raita
kind of a absolutely perfect this time
of year the season runs from April to
November and it's a great alternative to
Cod favor robust but it's got this
really nice snowflake appearance it's
right wide full of flavor and packed
with protein skin hold it towards the
tail and just tug the towel beautiful
look
all you do now you just cut nice big
thick slabs of halibut into the fridge
to firm up now we will make this really
amazing fresh tandoori paste start off
with some ginger garlic cumin coriander
seeds and the spices here we've got
chilli turmeric paprika a garam masala
basically hot warm spice row seeds salt
and that sort of intensifies the flavor
take a small knob of ginger and here old
Thompson's size knob
great add ginger into the pestle and
mortar three cloves of garlic
[Music]
toasted seeds in salt spice lemon
that starts to turn the page with a
really nice sharp vibrant fresh flavor
which you never get when you buy a
tandoori paste tomato puree and a couple
of tablespoons of ground nut oil mix the
color is extraordinary you don't get
that color when you buy a paste done
absolutely beautiful
now marinating the halibut yogurt paste
lemon sugar just to sort of chill the
flavor of the heat with all the spices
mix look at that color now beautiful
halibut in it goes spoon the marinade
over the head of a hot pan ground the
oil strange the pan leave that cooking
nice and gently for about two-and-a-half
to three minutes each side we're going
to serve it on a bit of cucumber
peel
he's one of them strips almost like
pappardelle pasta beautiful cucumbers of
all season
mint shop yogurt lemon absolutely
amazing cucumber in the center of the
plate
you've halibut is ready to come out and
watch
as amazing tandoori spice halibut with
chook embroider done
so the idea of the writer yeah is to
cool it down yes sir cucumber mint and
yogurt at the very end on taste at the
top
yes chef Sandra please do not burn yeah
[__] toast yes spinach on the side
yeah okay then from there fish up listen
yeah up very carefully don't you Trey
I'll move it over but yeah be very very
careful yeah little bit vinegar just to
touch in there over now anyone complains
about the presentation there yeah [__]
themselves okay fifty like that I
guarantee fifty will pay yes sure yes
let's go ladies please I don't want it
boiling or a nice coating
yeah of the marinade on there yes okay
really nice coating you think let's go
[Music]
danke Judas you need to keep an eye on
how long the fish have been in for
minimum five minutes yes [__] boys
yeah when you go first they do you speak
will you sit there silent gently it's
fish nests two tickets down yes twelve
to go come on fast food doesn't have to
mean bad food
[Music]
RAF Lucas Scotland home of one of the
world's fastest planes
[Music]
tomatoe f3
the pilots and navigators here are all
on QR a quick reaction alert when the
alarm sounds they have just minutes to
scramble to defend British airspace
these guys work at top speed but when it
comes to the kitchen they haven't got a
clue how to be quick morning main from
the time during the day we actually get
about maybe half an hour for lunch to
cook healthy food quickly at all that's
why at the moment in the short gap
between flying we're eating pretty
rubbish food the the state were in to be
honest we reduced to cheese toasties
it's pretty an adventurous worry for a
bunch of men that fly very expensive
nice toys these guys say they have no
time to cook but I'm here to prove no
matter how little time you have anyone
can cook good food fast what an absolute
beauty unbelievable
tornado it is f3 f3 look at it my god
was finest air defence fighter the best
of the best best of the best in cooking
terms it's three Michelin star watch the
speed of sound just over a thousand
miles an hour yeah a thousand miles an
hour just about that yeah yeah you fancy
trying to wait for ride world what I
would love to get anything
a lucky chef of them hair I'm not even
in there yet already wet my pants the
pilots can experience up to seven times
the force of gravity in the f3 so it's
vital aware the right kit
[Music]
beautiful
that's amazing
840 miles an hour that's 14 miles a
minute
[Music]
lady
a lifetime thank you very much
balls good fun guns
I tell you what's four kings I can t fo
keen thing yeah I've lost my appetite
I'm starving your style I am starving
you say you're gonna cook for me so def
strung me their skill in the air now
it's time to get them up to speed in the
kitchen still feel a little bit I'm
absolutely amazing I'm gobsmacked on the
back of what I've experienced and you
know a [__] thrill of a lifetime
without a shadow down you can't survive
on a toastie so with only 25 minutes
until their next fight I'm gonna teach
them how to cook something that doesn't
come between two slices of bread okay
gentlemen I feel the need for speed now
something very simple straightforward
I'm bloody good for you yeah a really
nice pan-roasted Cod with chorizo and a
fragrant rice peeler
softly is it fly off the trees oh you
give a very nice flavor to the car lover
to show you video gets right at this
time to get a move on
okay so news in there that's for the
right kardama bara dates a couple of
cloves cinnamon stick the smell of that
now is amazing
and for the club you will be cooking the
cod on the skin okay
hey it's packed with protein and it
keeps it nice and intact you lay there
way just to stop there's a bit of a
different sort of take on a toasting for
the guys yeah
what do you think you put that in a
toasty exactly no check on that rice and
we've already serve up guys
yeah now for me the most important thing
there of course was the speed that well
there's 12 minutes Alvin is happy this
is good food but fast food yeah it is
yeah
that was a [__] pleasure appetite
back yeah thank you
no extraordinary yeah stay off the
toasters yeah yeah and I'll stay at your
cockpit
[Music]
yeah touch that it's not good
back in back in back in quickly gently
don't shake the pan
you really are little cesspit look at
your [__] bowl clean down the hall
please
first last just a touch just a touch no
that is olive oil can't move you ladies
first table was [__] great now we're
just going to pot let's go clean the
plates temporally level yes happily that
happens very nice go
we will then sign it now no one's talked
to each other let's go
you're on the inside
yeah yeah it's two minutes away from
being cooked yes there is beautifully
cooked that bit in there it's raw yes
not good enough
send out wait they want your questions
yeah yeah let's go that's the most
amazing start
yes all the seven the main course we've
just deflated such a shame how long for
your fish we don't want it going out
wrong
that's nice nicely cooked Susan yeah yes
okay as you lift the fish yes
don't [__] it gently wash our Hickam
Susan
yeah nice go to 15 bye come in
Commissioner such a difficult fish to
cook yes yes but you've got to
understand it's better to be thirty
seconds over yeah 30 seconds under yes
I hope second time they went out yeah
they'll perfect yes yeah okay sit down
well then I guess off yes dear I did
it's beautifully cooked very subtly
spiced money in the fish it's really
lovely it's really well cooked really
nice despite ok right results the
commodities yeah main force results its
Gary okay JB okay
yes that means yeah if you get more than
27 out of 50 customers pay for the
dessert you'll knock those [__] eatin
boys off yes that doesn't mean to say
you take it easy encodes for make sure
that all 50 pay next on the menu James
May drinks his way through the recipe
challenge if you win this [__]
challenge so I'm gonna go man yeah it's
time for dessert
Scotch pancakes with caramelized bananas
hunting with a winged assassin bloody
good catch
welcome back Network now time for the
recipe challenge and my challenger is
James May yes captain slow so we may be
here for a long time
ready I'm ready how long will it take to
make the fish pie normally about four
hours four hours yeah lucky how do one
stage at a time you know then I go to
the pub and so you're slow at driving
and slow at cook you slower everything
also so James do the fish mine I'm gonna
do something very very similar except
I'm gonna be a bit of a cream sauce
fresh Pat's all new season Peas grain
mustard
that's the little sort of piss the
resistance I just heard you describing
yours mine is nothing like as elaborate
as that mine is fish with potato in the
form of a pie can I open this
I have I've got my own sir proper
waiters friend but it's got two steps in
it which makes a difference in
engineering terms so what fish have you
got in the pie
I've got undyed smoked haddock nice and
some whitefish I've got some Sherlock's
and Finland here who's going to put them
down a little bit of salt and pepper a
little bit of thyme and then I'm gonna
add the nollie prat
this is a Verma and that's gonna help
make the sauce well all I've done so far
is peeled roughly peeled and chopped up
my potatoes and my sweet potato which is
this thing I've only use half of whether
that's just to inform the flavour of the
traditional mashed potato
now I'm gonna poach my fish so you're
cooking your fish in milk James that
right yeah this milk that the fish is
poached in will also become the basis of
the sort of sauce thing that fills up
the bulk of the part I don't really know
what I'm talking about to be honest I
didn't usually by the time I get this
far I'm so drunk I can't remember what
I've done I'm gonna poach the prawns
just in seasoned water there a little
bit of lemon thyme
literally 30 seconds [__] the prawns I
forgot the prawns when Jamie's swearing
in my kitchen sorry you're putting the
prawns into the mill yes yeah and the
prawns are cooked already
I know but they've just got a heat
through
don't say I didn't warn you but I went
on listen this is your recipe you know
that yes that's the most important I
won't go through it with robber prawns
it makes me feel a lot more confident
that's very fast change there I think
I'm the first person Britain to actually
capture so go fast
yeah look at the speed that knife one of
us because I've got the knife very sharp
that's right peas are ready
miru a thing isn't thickening up Gordon
is that the roommate James you're the
room a right now the ruie the roof our
our UX the roof okay the rue is not
going very thick it's a bit sloppy does
that matter it depends I think you want
your pine the prawns are done are they
yeah you're right they have stroke i
cocked that up a bit
didn't I just to finish all the potatoes
now a little bit of grated nutmeg change
do you always drink like this when
you're cooking stoves the horror of the
food that I'm gonna eat later obviously
if you win this [__] challenge now
I'm gonna go mad you know where to go
just watching you yeah seriously
drink taste drink taste drink tasting
tape extraordinary no that's great
yeah I need to do is put me multicolored
mashed potato on top and a bit piece is
that how you know me they're pasted on
yeah when I ask you do like a [__]
plaster oh well this is the bit you can
also a leash honestly I would like a
like this is like a trowel no I'd like a
chef's tip how do I do the middle this
is the mirror but I've always struggled
I would suggest you put it in your hand
cut out
paste it on there Pat it Pat it out on
and what James Devine looms against that
seriously I'm gonna give up cooking look
Miley ensures yeah I know they're not
cooked yet but I've got a color in mind
though I mean that's pretty pretty cool
there's a hair in it I don't want any
[__] hands in mine fish pie please
quickly know what can we get in the
[__] over now no James look at the
time it's got a right word on the top
what you put it on top cop
I've had that there next to yours the
last ten minutes I hope the [__] it
doesn't affect it yes wish sickness
right ready for the other now yes where
is it uh I'll go bottom you'll go bottom
right you've got your oven to off
yeah no it's on 200 we go speed up a
little bit change all about Brian okay
both pies in for half an hour thank you
yes
half an hour later blind tasting we'll
taste them and then you'll lose okay
yourself of Chef Ramsay that let a
single drink this series I'm hunting
high and low for great ingredients
I'm on my way to Norfolk in search of
something quite unique something that
means a lot to me
hair is my favorite type of game they're
bigger and tastier than rabbit but
running at 40 mile an hour they're
harder to hunt shooting I'm gonna be
using a bird of prey to sort of hunt it
down
shooting hair often results in a spoiled
carcass and hunting hair with dogs have
been banned by using a bird of prey
the meat is killed cleanly and swiftly
in a totally natural way from a chef's
point of view a dream come true I'm
going to see George hedges who's been a
falconer all his life all these birds
are lean mean killing machines but to
take down a ham I need something bigger
than a falcon something huge
the ultimate bird of prey the golden
eagle
he's absolutely [__] gorgeous look at
the size of him Jordan Lee
Donna's amazing yeah I'm gonna put that
there bro we step on Jack love yeah okay
you can feel the power
okay
[Laughter]
put down with a slowly down this hand
here okay Shawn that's 3,000 pound you
own me now now it's time for the hunt
once the Eagles airborne is just a
matter of time until he spots a hair
[Music]
but once he's made the kill you've got
to be quick before the powerful bird
rips its prey and your dinner apart
[Music]
bloody good cash my gosh bloody hell
you've owned that already
God Almighty no let show anywhere
no nothing blasted we've never used the
head anyway but that's one perfect hair
I'm going to take the hair back home and
hanging for a couple of days to improve
the flavor then I'm going to cook it for
the kids tea that's the saddle and with
that we're gonna do the most amazing
fricassee of hair with a rich dark
chocolate sauce and look fake gamey it's
very rich
faylene that is a jewel in any kitchen I
throw in some shallots new season
turnips garlic and a little sugar crush
some juniper berries and black
peppercorns and chop some rosemary now
look at that Wow everything in that pan
is so delicious and gives a really nice
foundation to a quick fricassee with a
hare now it's time for the kill
loin in one and a half to two minutes in
there the sad thing about hair never
gets looking because everyone's
fascinated with rabbit very lean packed
with protein and incredibly good for you
pour some red wine into the pan and
reduce it add a chicken stock bringing
up to the ball and then thicken it with
a bit of magic chocolate bitter
chocolate
add the hair I'm throwing some parsley
all right guys
dinnertime tell me what you think it is
no but make the shorter gravy Jack chili
do you like that it's you've got
chocolate your nose 45 out of 50 ma
absolutely brilliant yeah 33 out of 50
disappointing pull it back now okay
let's go Justin six portions wait Susan
student work together six portions away
last course big moment time for dessert
Scotch pancakes we can rise bananas and
rum and vanilla ice cream pancakes why
do you only eat them in February once a
year Shrove Tuesday which is crazy this
is an american-style pancake light
fluffy and absolutely delicious start
off with 150 grams of flour and sift the
flour as you pour into the bowl baking
powder
keeps the pancake really nice and light
and fluffy salt 3 eggs
75 mils of water and a hundred and
twenty mill of buttermilk and the secret
behind this pancake mix is to make sure
that we've got no lumps anywhere whisk
the eggs into the flour get your
buttermilk just add half of it in give a
really good whisk that's nice and smooth
already the rest of the buttermilk so
when you make your pancake mix like this
it's chemistry so follow the recipe
exactly now we got this really nice
smooth batter that's ready perfect
nonstick pan sunflower oil and just run
that around half a ladle in a minute or
half on each side absolutely onto the
plate this is where it gets really
exciting we're can rising bananas it's
important to slice them lengthwise in
order to make sure that they don't go
mushy in the pan I'm going to make a
really nice quick caramel 50 grams of
sugar back off the heat and start the
camera don't whisk it don't put spoon in
there just leave it in the pan once
you're happy with the color take it back
off the heat butter bananas I'm going to
do now is to glaze the pan with some
run-run banana camera goes brilliantly
nice
lovely think of the flavor a little cup
of water just to let the caramel down so
it's not too sticky and rich and too
thick there we go that's ready you
generous with them because it is just
the ultimate in Dalton and then finally
to finish it it's a really nice ice
cream on top and drizzle that over very
very quick and easy scotch pancakes
caramelized bananas with rum and vanilla
ice cream done beautiful then one of the
Americans are so [__] fan the caramel
gets too hot take the pan off yes you're
more than capable of doing this chef
panic yeah let's go
move your ass [__] l-ladies is more
swearing come a few for Little Miss Mila
scarify guys ready yes right there too
dark
yeah too dark too dark too dark yes stop
stop stop stop someone nicely done some
are not done yes get that [__] out
that's far too dark they toss them don't
toss to be very careful ranma-honey
that's enough turn around come on Polly
Sandra look you got to help yourself now
ladies now careful watch your eyebrows
ask you now right ready there we go
there you go out on the truth thank you
exactly sit good come on please we're
coming Garden we're coming
can we dust the pancakes before we put
the bananas on okay everything's done
beautifully yet we're just slopping it
no one gives a [__] how they put things
on a plate here anymore yes come on
Justine go to weigh the play my darling
yeah you make all this amazing food and
then he just pulls it up by dirting
everywhere just a t-shirt yep are you
happy with them yes service please
how are you my darling I'm good evening
how I see you I see you look great thank
you
very good very beautiful the guy's
daughter yeah great mine fantastic
because I said about my dessert now
they're really good oh my god in a
bloody good job Legolas is strong and on
the ball yeah you've always been a bit
of a foodie is there anything you'd
never eat I'm not a fussy eater really
quite venture completely favorite kind
of food is comfort food I've been
spending lots of time in this state so
as soon as I came home I want to have my
roast dinner and some fish and chips la
beating out scene there don't get fed up
with a sort of egg white omelets and
sort of tofu I do Percy I don't I refuse
to do it because when I first arrived
there I was told well yeah you know it's
very competitive and I shouldn't maybe
lose consider losing white specific
Rudy's near would you mind losing weight
otherwise not going employee you know I
we sat next to Nicole rich in a
restaurant yes you know he's tiny size
zero she's like that a stick insect
can you feel like going up to us at
hello is it merely looking for scary I
don't like it and I honestly think I'm
so into it because I think when you're
in the public eye yeah well you have a
risk modernity yeah and my goddaughter
was 14 years old and she reads these
trashy magazines and everything and she
thinks that is beauty you know
prostrates me from which s point of view
that they sort of get upset with not
eating eating well makes you feel well I
do one last question you're a judge on
judges obviously go out for London from
time to time I do yes doesn't Andrew
Lloyd Webber's Facebook of your food do
my love
send him down could the same thank so
much for come and enjoy dessert yes next
on the menu
Cooper Lee Whitman still helps and put
the spring into spring lambs yes find
out who b2 in the recipe challenge so we
win it
the winner is remember if you think
you've got a rotate to become the next
big female TV cook then send me a video
here are some of my favorites so far I'm
gonna start by cutting up some ginger
and some garlic you're gonna need some
olive oil I'm saying that it should be
more women on television more exciting
women on television and not just skinny
blondes either
[Music]
groans I know it has brothers make the
making gingerbread men my make
gingerbread women and the women have a
little message for you Gordon
welcome back there Boyd now time for
James May to lose the recipe challenge
ready to plate up behind yes yes nice
little description on there it should be
Shi T yes no I see right there yours is
quite runny what's that is that a yeah
that's Santa please don't finger my pie
right is that portion big enough James
made up this please yes obviously come
back with the right result
good luck yes yeah
[Laughter]
good good so they're happy yeah very
French mob yeah three two three two
yeah I got two so then we win it the
winner is come on James what yeah with
that pile of shake yeah love it's cool
no salt are you any good at driving
oh [__] around are you two up to strong
flavors eaten by a [__] shaggy [__]
yeah I spent four rounds [__]
potatoes do something very quickly for
me please yes [__] up out of it please
oh my god
I don't just want the Sheep in my back
garden to grow I want them to grow up
happy my Welsh Lambs Charlotte and Gavin
are now 8 weeks old and supplementing
their milk with spring grass they're
grown rapidly but I'm worried they may
be finding life on my garden a bit dull
compared to the Welsh mountains so I've
asked my friend Hugh Foley which install
to come and check their active enough
it's amazing how quickly growing you
know yeah what do you think what I could
say is that those lambs are growing well
yes no question he's just not skeptical
about the back garden I'm very skeptical
but they are wild
you've got wild sheep in the suburban
garden I mean it's not like they're
having a miserable time you know lots
all but it's it's not a Welsh hillside
is it what we just need to do here I
think it's a little bit of environmental
enrichment
[Music]
she wanted to give the sheep a bit of
extra stimulation by giving them
something to climb on
look Gordon all of the lambs is sniffing
the mountain hmm she's interested look
yes a little playground gives my lambs a
chance to tone up exercise and generally
enjoy life a bit more the joys of spring
that we might have found a way to keep
Sharla and Gavin amused but they're
stuck with the old lawn my back garden
is beginners look a bit threadbare
patchy it's already not much left is
there you know
if they stay here much longer you won't
have a lawn really and they won't ever
need to eat I've got something to turn
on keep them off the grass for a day or
two nice spring greens and kale lovely
and what do you think of their size it's
good enough for me sweetener you could
be deep-frying that a seaweed green from
selling it for ten pounds of forces in
the restaurant I'm gonna give it to your
sheep come on girls
these Dorset greens will give my sheep
some extra nutrients and minerals but
won't stop my lawn from being devoured
in a week's time there'll be nothing
left here so I think you've got to find
some other grass I think you have to get
on the phone to some of your friends and
see if someone else has got a nice bit
of garden area is the regulars at your
restaurant we've got big gardens in
London David Victoria I'm sure they'd
love to have your sheep to stay with me
yeah well I'm awesome yeah but well get
on the phone
who else Tony Blair do you think 10
Downing Suites got any grass checkers
got lots of grass checkers that's not
too far out of town not too far out at
dear Tony I wonder if I could ask you a
favor I need to find new pastures Davina
how am I done is Gordon how are you
Rance right mr. Jonathan Ross it's
Gordon how are you dear mom yes as an
offer of the British Empire I'm writing
to request your help for a very
important issue risotto is a pig
paradise right come on damn Johnny
Vaughn's got astroturf and you've got no
grass left Dan I said no Lambs yes and
your garden is it possible oh by the way
PS I still polished my OBE every day
love Gordon did you say love to the
Queen just when things seemed bleak I
got lucky
you've really seriously pulled me on the
[__] I can assure you thank you I'll see
you next week Thanks
thank God for that grass
Thank You 14 the plank good a little bit
of sauce expensi now break away do the
ice cream good girl
good now look at the difference this
table here look fantastic and you're
working team and the bananas aren't much
good that looks fantastic really good
anyway go [__] off well done last table
I really really enjoyed it was it was a
good way to end the meal that we had it
really did take the box out to you it's
just a nice combination and all the
different flavors in the pancake was
really nicely cooked right ladies let's
go
results of the desserts yes give that to
me please yes thank you okay working out
right now for this next course you need
to have 27 or more to come back with the
possibility of running Claridge's
suspense is 48 so that means you have a
total of 126 out of 150 which is [__]
good you that means more money in a
sense for the eating boys and the lanky
less is in pole position